新しいベイブレードを張ってから約3週間が経った
あのハマりすぎちゃって日付いたらこんなにたくさん買っちゃいました
楽しいですよ木はのベレット超楽しいですよ何だろうねあれ母校レットというのは音
でかいんですよ
ん
バーやべたのしてやっぱり音壊れできていいよ
壊すって楽しいブログでベイブレードにドハマリしてるんですけど僕命名とするとき
いつもこのスタジオに行ってるんですけどもまぁこのスタジアムもですね僕もん
何千回とばはしてきたんでなかなか傷ついてきても結構頃ボルド部というで今日はた
まね違う場所でレイドやってみたとか思ったわけなんで
今回新しいステージを準備しましたこちら
今日はダンボールを挟みと手を使うことなく開けてみたよ
とんだ無駄が作業だけどよ
押木た貼ってみました
今で方はこちら中華鍋ですいやもう中華一龍のは恐ろしくと元を超え調理器具としてか
たわけじゃないですか血税のスタジアムと思ってもかかりましたかね
うわぁ凄い
あっはああすげえやっ
完全にしたじゃうっすよねアニメのベイベーとかとねこういう場所でベイブレードする
んですよ i0多分ちークラブでやってんじゃねーかこれはすごいよ普及のたじゃんと
比べると大きさはかなり違いますね
ただけっこ深いからさーなんかね売っとんだりすることはない気がします
ua 回してたら早速まわしてみましょうじゃあまずは屋外しているヴァルキリーだよ
楽しみましょう
攻撃タイプだとぐレベルもあるんで道具かがポイントですねツリー
2まあ号
なんだとヴァルキリーが通用しない
me
アナンドた口調できたとあんまり大ぶりに改善しすぎると深すぎて側面が買って止まっ
ちゃいます
うるさーフレアちょっと defense タイプでやってみます姿勢最後は真ん中に
泊まるんで多分大丈夫だと思います
ee
oc
ああああああ
いいんじゃないディフェンサー日はちょっとできるねさてと戦ってみますか
最近の僕の中で一番する defense タイプなやつと受給力なるドライバーなん
ですけど攻撃タイプのレイヤーエクスカリバーですねちょっとこいつらで戦ってみ
ましょう
オーナー時になるタイプじゃないんで割と落ち着いた試合になると思います
day 2は格子
はぁやべぇブッ飛んでっちゃったう
ああああああああ
goo
結果中華鍋でレベルのするとプリザー
def 4